[Music]
if you've been following rocket
launchers recently you'll have seen
this but also this stage one Landing
confirmed while we've been launching
Rockets into space for nearly a century
now we're only just starting to figure
out how to land them and reuse them and
while SpaceX may be the dominant name in
reusable Rockets it's not the only
player trying to make them it just
doesn't make any sense to throw those
away after every single use us startup
Stoke space is also trying to build a
fully reusable rocket system that it
says could ually be relaunched in as
little as 24 hours after landing back on
Earth that's the company's plan anyway
but right now it's not quite there
yet so as always we're going to look at
where stok space is now where it wants
to be and then explore what it needs to
do to get there but let's start with
where the company wants to be stok space
has aims to create a rocket where every
part of it is rapidly reusable when we
started the company in 2019 I was kind
of passionate about making rocket launch
boring now it turns out that's not a
great headline but that's what you want
you want it to be so routine that people
aren't thinking about it now you may be
thinking doesn't SpaceX already do this
and it does kind of three 2 1 the
company is currently reusing these parts
of its Falcon 9 rocket system but not
these parts and it's obviously been
working towards getting it Starship
spacecraft to land and relaunch and
others like rocket Labs have also been
working on getting this part the first
stage that gets you from Earth to space
to be reusable but Stoke space is taking
a different approach the big puzzle
piece that hasn't been solved yet by the
industry is reusable upper stage and so
that's where we started with our
technical development to be able to get
its second stage back down to Earth stok
space plans to move away from the
traditional heat shields that have been
used on previous aircraft traditionally
you use either a system that literally
Burns away as it re-enters so that's you
know almost by definition not reusable
this typically used on capsule style
re-entry so think about Apollo or um soy
or even Dragon the other option is
ceramic tiles which were used on the
shuttle they used on Starship now uh but
those are are quite brittle that's why
the company has opted for this metallic
heat shield which it says will be
actively cooled on re-entry but placing
a heat shield on the underside of a
spacecraft that's trying to land upright
creates another issue how do you now
bury a high performance rocket engine
into the base heat shield right and so
that's where the ring of fire so to
speak comes from now while the company
is launching satellites to begin with
Andy told me there was no reason why the
system couldn't scale up to eventually
carry human beings though he sees a
future where the spacecraft are used as
service vessels for a space station I
think Starship helps us lay heavy
infrastructure in space I think it helps
us you know realize commercial space
stations and and I think that's awesome
that pushes the entire industry forward
creates new market opportunities but
space stations could be quite a way off
off so where is stok space now well in
addition to having manufacturing
facilities near Seattle and test
facilities near Moses Lake Washington
the company has also managed to secure
dedicated launch capacity at Cape
Canaveral in a facility right next to
where SpaceX first landed its Falcon 9
Stoke space Also recently announced that
it had received $100 million in series B
funding and that's in addition to the
over $70 million it had received over
previous years and it has begun testing
its second stage propulsion that ring of
fire it even conducted a short test
flight and while this may have only been
a small hop it was a giant leap for the
company Hopper was a fullscale end to
end flight demonstration had avionics
comms flight computers software
batteries the whole nine yards were on
there we learned a lot from that as well
but getting from small test hops to a
fully reusable rocket system could be
quite a difficult Journey literally
rocket science even after success
entering the Earth's atmosphere which is
by no means an easy feat stok space
second stage then has to successfully
land which as SpaceX has proven time and
time again isn't exactly easy to master
now the engines are operating at a very
very low throttle and with effectively
empty tanks it's doing Telemetry
tracking positioning navigation trying
to get it onto the correct ground track
in order to land on wherever it's trying
to land and even if stok space achieved
these Milestones it still has to prove
to its customers that rockets that have
been used time and time again are just
as safe and reliable as brand new ones
so for stok space to make rapidly
reusable full Rockets a commercial
reality the company is going to need to
complete testing of its reusable second
stage and deploy it commercially develop
all the other parts of the rocket which
is by no means a small feat successfully
launch land and relaunch every part of
those rockets and convince customers its
reusable rocket is safe and effective
but even if stok space can achieve all
this the company is still taking on
SpaceX at its own game so in order to
find success it's going to have to offer
something that space X isn't whether
that be faster cheaper or smaller rocket
launchers